COREY SYVRET AND ERIC FURLATT
AND
BALCERS.
SAVE, REBOUND IN FRONT OFRE
GOING TO CREATE SPACE UP HIGH.
THAT IS A TRADEUTURE FIRST ON TD
THE SAVE MADE
LOOK HOW ONE SHOT TURNS PIPE.
KRISTIAN VESALAINEN FOR SVECHNI.
HE WILL TAKE A BUMP ON THE NET.
SAVE MADE AND CHANGES THE FLOW.
A NICE JOB FROM WHEELER JUST TO
GET IT THERE AND WE SAW THAT A S
AND THE SAN JOSE SHARKS HAVE THE
GAME'S OPENING THIS
FOR HELLEBUYCK AS HE HAS TO
RESPECT THE SHOT.
>> Kevin: SAN JOSE GETS ANEST
CHANCE OF THE GAME COMES FROM A
BIT OFND GRABBED OFF BY KYLE
CONNOR.
TRYING TO GET AN ODD-MAN RUSH
GOING.
IN TIGHT.
THIS IS A   TONINATO, NHLPOINT .
SPIN-O-RAMA GOAL LAST GAME WAS
PERIOD JUST BEFORE THE PERIODIER
PIERRE-LUC DUBOIS.ADE BY RIEMS.
>> Kevin:
LITTLE BIT ON NUMBER 81..
CLEARED IN BY NATE SCHMID
>> Kevin: TWO
BRAKES.
HERTL WITH BONINO.
THE SHOT, SA. TWO-ON-ONE.
GOOD
SHOT FROM THE LINE.IPPER.
CHICAGO. WINNING THAT FACEOFF BY
TIMING IS EVERYTHING ON THE
TWO-ON-ONE AND ADAM THIS YEAR
RIGHT FROM THE PUCK DROP.
>> Dennis: FACEOFF WIN
BY THE SHARKS.
LOGAN COUTURE HAS BEEN DYNAMITE
IN THE FA YOU.
MARIO FERRARO FIRST PERIOD.
ONE WAS A GOAL.
INTERCEPTED.
YOU WANT THE DEFENCE.ERY LOLO
LOOK AT THERE.
HOLD THE